ladies and gentlemen please welcome
ralph macchio
what an intro thank you drew that was
awesome
oh no you have no idea how hard this is
for me to contain myself
i i don't remember a time in my life
where i didn't love you
and you're so important to me do it for
johnny
i love that movie that's just this is
wonderful it's wonderful to see you
um through uh technology and uh
been a super fan myself so this is this
will be a love fest
now is it true that we saw each other
at the et auditions yes
but it was no you it was i was
offered um the possibility of playing
the role of
tyler i think that was the character's
name see thomas howell
my outsiders greaser buddy ponyboy
actually played that part
but i had i wanted to we wanted to read
the script so they said oh you have to
go into
spielberg's office you can't have the
script and
and read it i'm sitting there by myself
um
under lock and key reading e.t the
extraterrestrial
when this little adorable girl comes up
to me and says says
hi i'm drew what part are you playing
and i just i was half
enamored by this adorable little girl
and the other side of my brain was like
kid they told me i have an hour to read
this and i gotta get back to it
it was wonderful so we it's it's we we
have to not wait 30 blah blah years next
time
i would be so happy if we did not
have to wait any time at all and it's
been such a
pleasure to grow up in this industry
um not only alongside of you but just
watching you and having you be someone
that was
so important to our generation and
generations and as someone who
tried to responsibly take a beloved
franchise
like a charlie's angels and modernize it
the karate kid is so beloved and
important
what spoke to you about cobra kai and
did you know like this will
maintain the respect that's at your
level of expectations
that's a great question it was you know
something that i
over the years was pitched oh this is
how to go back
and do this or play daniela russo again
or or tap into this universe and it
never made any sense to me
until this time the three creators of
our show
um are the biggest fanboys of the karate
kid franchise it is star wars to them
um they had a very smart angle in of
coming through the eyes of the williams
zabka character johnny lawrence and
how can you flip the prism and
perspective of a story we all know and
love
learn something about another character
and then enter that world and the film
creed had just
come out when i first heard this pitch
and that was sort of the way into the
rocky balboa world without making rocky
seven
or eight or nine or whatever they were
up to so it was a it was a smart angle
in
we have the streaming services that now
allow you
to tell five hour movies and ten half
hour parts
that didn't exist uh uh ten years ago
so it allowed the characters to breathe
and us dive into gray areas and explore
um you know the next generation if you
will as well as the
og legacy characters so it i come up
looking way smart right now but
i took a shot no i think you do know
especially you know i grew up playing
charlie's angels but i
i wasn't attached to the original
um in the way that you were with the
karate kid
you do know because you know when
something tonally
is intelligent inventive and
in keeping with and cobra kai
is so crisp so smart so brilliant i
i was studying the writers and directors
and like how it all came about
they they are they are great they they
um you know just have their eye on the
on the prize the eye on the ball they
never
let go of the nostalgia and the the
feels and the heart and the soul and yet
there's a heightened reality to it
there's a wish fulfillment element
and uh and then there's a badass element
as well so we're
striking on all cylinders and it feels
great it's
very cool and it strikes on incredible
human
themes how is it being the mentor now
yeah outside of the years and decades
that have gone by and the realization
that i ain't the kid no more
um it's it's kind of wonderful i wasn't
expecting this drew i really wasn't
expecting to have
uh and take as much pride as i do
working with our young cast
they're fantastic and without them you
know the story doesn't continue
and so you know it's bittersweet it's
nostalgia
it's that feeling that okay i was once
that young kid and now how can i pay it
forward and give it back
and and share a piece of what i've
learned and
and positivity going forward and
and uh hand it off to the the young cast
and they give me as much back
as uh as i think i might be giving to
them so
yeah outside of getting older it's been
it's been great
well it first of all you look insanely
good i don't know what like water you're
drinking what is going on
you look incredible we were all talking
about it
and you did grow up in this industry
and in fact we were talking about
having done a lot of childhood
commercials
and you know you're talking about the
wisdom you apply to the younger people
on the set now
we were just kids and and we would you
know
make commercials do you remember that
like
yes yes there's oh there's always one
that that lives no matter
no matter where you go um but it's your
first time in front of the camera you
know
it's uh it was kind of
fun i did this bubble yum commercial i
did two of them
and it's um yeah i think i try
it's it's fun i don't know i'm like
backtracking
brilliant choreography how about the
outfits
yes yes i remember the whole the whole
jingle
it was uh fun but it got me the next
part so i guess uh
i guess i didn't suck well i was doing
the same
thing it's just it's amazing it's so
cool to kind of share that
it's so fun to reminisce about the old
days
and the way that you are in these modern
times the whole
thing and everything in between i'm just
so excited to be talking to you
you